enfin c'est tout pour la page politique
j'aurais pu être plus méchant vu la
semaine qu'on est
plein de Guillaume
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
prendre la place de clémentine quand
même elle est chaude encore oui c'est
vrai
j'ai essayé de faire un papier autour du
gouvernement histoire de faire plaisir à
comme dirait Bedos qu'elle ne soit pas
venue pour rien Morano elle je sais pas
pourquoi elle m'énerve
suite au drame de Villiers-le-Bel salut
en l'initiative de Courbevoie qui grâce
à des simulations d'accidents apprend à
ses élèves à éviter les voitures de
police
contre la violence urbaine les policiers
prennent l'hélico c'est pratique qui et
puis il y a peu de motos volantes qui
viennent te barrer la route
international Chine Nicolas Sarkozy très
discret sur les droits de l'homme 8000
condamnés à mort par an une balle dans
la nuque c'est pour ça il faut faire
très gaffe aux Jeux Olympiques cet été
en tirent le chinois va être très fort
je rappelle que les inondés du Mexique
sont d'ores et déjà imbattables en
natation synchronisée
d'après Le Figaro la Chine doit cesser
devant les organes de ces condamnés à
mort et surtout les yeux parce qu'une
grève Dieu et chinoise se voit tout de
suite ça se voit
Rama Yade écartée du voyage présidentiel
waouh c'est pas indispensable une
secrétaire d'État droit de l'homme pour
aller en Chine en revanche si Sarkozy va
en Suède à Monaco Luxembourg là ouais
et enclos cette page politique avec un
cliché extrêmement rare Nicolas Sarkozy
assis sans ses annuaire
c'est tout pour la page politique
j'aurais pu méchant vu la semaine qu'on
est
fait divers un camion heurte un train
régional bah oui mais bon des jours de
grève on a plus l'habitude de s'arrêter
au passage à niveau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les voiles sur berges passent à 50 km/h
Lady Di s'était battu toute sa vie pour
une vitesse libre en bord de Seine
Marc Lavoine et Patrick Bruel dans Gala
alors on sait que Bruel traverse une
période difficile
de la choper Marc Lavoine
les Mary plaquées ont des pulsions en ce
moment deuxième photo
tendresse quand tu nous tiens
Yannick Noah bientôt acteur
Yannick Noah qui devait partir si
Sarkozy était président
[Applaudissements]
pour Noël sortie du film Le Renard et
l'Enfant avec tous ces bébés bouffés par
des chiens je sais pas si c'était le bon
moment
Orlando membre du jury Miss France 2008
excellente idée c'est comme demander à
un végétarien délire la meilleure côte
de bœuf
et on termine avec un sourire gala
cherche une femme pour Nicolas Sarkozy
alors plusieurs propositions bon une
fois de plus Nadine n'a pas été retenu
décidément tant mieux plusieurs
propositions la navigatrice Florence
Arthaud oui si elle emmène Sarkozy
autour du monde
Yasmina Reza non elle est d'origine
hongroise de Hongrois ensemble porte-feu
va gueuler
Inès de la Fressange trop grande un
mètre 80 trop grande Sharon Stone ça
c'est bien Basic Instinct on décroise
les gens le même geste avec Bernadette
Chirac sortez une frisée 4 jours du
frigo vous verrez
voilà moi Sharon Stone qui sort avec le
petit Bonaparte ça me plaît comme ça si
l'ouvre un coup de pic à glace sur la
tronche terminée voilà c'est fini voilà
Stéphane Guillon merci Stéphane et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu